hey youtubers is Charlie and during my
birds-of-prey review I asked you to
submit all of your questions about the
rest of the season
everyone was asking about Ravager
everyone wants to know about you know
who the next big death is and people are
starting to wonder who the next big
villain is going to be after slade so
because there is so much awesome that we
have to talk about let's just get right
in it
like normal I picked 10 of your
questions with one bonus question to
answer
careful for potential spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet but here we
go question number one comes from mr.
Alucard rules who asks what do you think
the episodes city of blood will be about
it sounds like they're just teasing that
brother Bloods going to be spreading the
serum across the city you know creating
his army of blood since that's so much
further ahead in the story it's also
possible that he could have become mayor
at that point
brother blood hasn't been featured a lot
since Slade's story came to the
forefront which you know I totally don't
mind
Slade's awesome I just haven't felt like
he's been a threat though to team arrow
he's been like Slade's Squire
you know the underling that runs off to
get him coffee and moisturizer for that
empty eye socket so city of blood will
just be his chance to come roaring back
into the story I'm also kind of hoping
that we might see some comic book
flashbacks to his childhood - question
number two is results and asks do you
think that Roy getting shot in the hand
is a nod to Arsenal that's actually a
really interesting idea I didn't think
that right away but it's totally
possible for those that don't know there
was a comic book story where Roy got his
arm chopped off that version of the
character wasn't enhanced by a mirakuru
not that mirakuru could help you grow
your arm back but all the same it did
spend several lines of dialogue with Roy
telling Oliver that you know this wounds
no big deal it'll be healed by tomorrow
so it's totally possible that you know
he will be getting a super serious
injury in the future
no like arm getting chopped off serious
question number three Sriram asks did we
just see summer Glaus character fight
Oliver does that mean she'll work with
Slade this is pretty far-fetched but
could she be Slade's daughter so you're
talking about ravager and my initial
thought was yes that was Summer Glau in
the trailer I had to take a screen grab
to double-check but in all the frames
her arm was covering up her face a
little but the person seems like she was
the right build to be
Summer Glau you know really tall really
thin very punchy very flexible if you
don't know before she started in Firefly
for joss whedon she was a professional
dancer
mostly ballet so she was super flexible
which is why it's easy for her to do all
those Dancy beautiful fight moves the
whole conceit of all this is that Isabel
may have been working with Slade this
whole time to take control of Queen
industries for hive
even though Isabel is a character from
the comic books already I did kind of
tease that it would be possible for her
to either be you know Thalia or ravaging
her or some other comic book character
in disguise because it just seemed too
good to be true to have someone who
actually played a terminator come on
arrow and not be terminating anyone
hopefully episode 18 won't answer some
of those questions although some of what
we learned about her in that Russia
episode does kind of line up with
Ravagers backstory I mean it just makes
so much sense you know wouldn't you cast
a terminator as Deathstroke the
Terminator daughter it would be so
beautiful I think that'd be a great
episode title the terminators daughter
question number four Michael Paulsen
asks do you think the Thea will figure
out Roy or Oliver's secret identities
during her rescue mission yes I
definitely think she'll find out they're
involved in the war with Slade and then
later they'll just come clean and tell
her at the full story I think that he is
actually gonna pull a similar move to
Laurel last week and just let the
darkness in remember how pissed she was
that people had been lying to her if it
turns out that she's not the one that's
going to die this season that I do kind
of expect her to become the next
unofficial member of team arrow a lot of
people have been wondering if she's ever
gonna become the Mia Dearden character
just because Moira's maiden name was
Deardon not to be super morbid but I do
hope that Morra ends up dying and that
inspires Thea to join the quote unquote
family business question number five
Nick Wong asks based on this episode it
doesn't look like it was the Huntress
that knocked out Diggle during the
promise who do you think it is now so
yeah since the Huntress didn't end up
being as big a character as I'd hoped
the next best guess is either Isabel or
Ravager obviously thinking that those
are the same person
I saw a lot of you guys suggesting that
it also might be Nyssa but I think if it
were her because we already knew her she
was already in an established character
they would have shown her face
it's totally possible though that the
actress that played Nyssa wasn't
available the day they film that devil
scene but for now based on what we've
seen my best guess is Isobel question
number six Darkfire karai asks with all
of her Lance teaming up with arrow do
you think it's only a matter of time
before he gets into trouble for doing so
definitely he totally hit that other
officer on the head to protect Oliver
the big teaser for man under the hood
episode 19 is people learning all of her
secret identity and remember brother
blood did have some people inside the
police department that minion
masquerading his brother blood was
killed but that doesn't mean that
Quentin has the full support of the
department now the way I see his
character is a lot like Jim Gordon
during Batman year one you know he was a
rookie cop that had to clear out
corruption in the department before
eventually becoming Commissioner Gordon
obviously Quentin isn't a rookie but I
think he's on the same path and just to
be clear I don't think he's gonna die
they've invested way too much time in
that character the Batman Gordon
parallels are just way too awesome to
drop any potential future storylines
Paul Blackthorne is such a great actor
and you just don't get rid of your
a-team which is why they totally didn't
officially kill John Barrowman you know
he's just way too awesome plus there's
that whole Captain Jack immortality
thing going on in the background
question number 7 the PT md3 asks do you
think there's gonna be a Bane Batman
repair you know where Batman takes a
bullet for bein so Bane saves him with
the Lazarus Pit between Slade and Oliver
so they've been posting a lot of images
for the next couple of episodes where
Oliver just keeps getting madder and
madder and I think that they want us to
believe that he's going to try and kill
Slade especially now with him capturing
Thea but I don't think it's gonna go
down like that what does he say during
the intro for every single episode this
season I can't be the killer I once was
implying that he's gonna show Slade
mercy at some point I do think that
Slade will show him mercy or at least
help him out in a fight it all really
depends on the ratio ghoul cameo working
out Marc Guggenheim and Manu Bennett
have both teased it they did say that
that all depends on a lot of stuff
behind the scenes working out because
there's some rights issues and it's such
a major character they have to cast him
so it's still unconfirmed
still not happen question number eight
Laurie and Anna asks do you think that
Slade is just in a mirakuru rage or is
there a little bit more oven that has
turned evil so that's actually what
we're gonna learn about in episode 18
we'll actually get a good look at what
the mirakuru has done to his brain for
the last six years mostly made him crazy
it's a lot like the psychosis people
experienced after using the Lazarus Pit
you know they just go temporarily insane
I think that madness will end up being
Slade's cross to bear just for the rest
of his long you know very long mirakuru
enhanced the life it's gonna be like a
wound that never heals something he just
has to live with like every time
Wolverine popping his claws in it
hurting really bad question number nine
Brad bought films asks did you notice
all the red in the episode yes most
people took that to mean red arrow and
Red Hood teaser I think it's mostly
foreshadowing Roy's Arsenal persona and
brother Bloods plan to convert the city
you know blood red that is there's also
this Nightwing symbol in an earlier
episode it's just a really easy way for
them to include references to characters
without creating the burden of casting
them or finding ways to fit more
intellectual property into a story than
is absolutely necessary
most of the time is just like a really
quick wink like gale street and Simone
Avenue during birds-of-prey just a
really quick shot here and there I try
not to look too much into it but it does
make it really fun to try and watch
episodes to look for Easter eggs like
that question number 10 crystal X asks
who would be the most unexpected
character to die I would say the most
unexpected would obviously be Oliver
Hillier main character the only way that
would work is if they featured the
Lazarus Pit or arrows version of the
Lazarus Pit which I don't think is the
mirakuru which some people have
suggested mirakuru can't really bring
someone back from the dead and most of
the time it just straight up kills
people of the people I actually think
are gonna die the most unexpected I
think would be Thea you know usually you
call the weak ones out of the herd and
Moira feels like she's just been blowing
a lot of smoke this season Thea on the
other hand could totally become a
superhero in her own right even the
right story arc which might be what
they're doing right now
so if she dies it would be super
unexpected and super happy accident
I included two bonus questions so here
we go the first one pepper Jim asks how
do you think that the death stroke story
will end
I think it'll end with Alvord defeating
Slade and then kind of ending as
frenemies I think Oliver will bring
Slade partially back to sanity and then
they'll just part ways you know not as
friends but as brothers that just really
hate each other they really push the
idea of them as brothers during the
promise and I think that theme is going
to come back around before the finale I
don't think Slade's gonna die though I
mean they didn't even kill Merlyn plus
who else here wants a Deathstroke
spin-off or a Teen Titans spin-off that
Slade is just a huge part of they really
wouldn't be able to do any of that stuff
if they killed the character so I think
they definitely want him to come back at
least in a small way next season and
last bonus question PG IR asks if all of
our defeats Slade who's gonna be the
season 3 villain so based on my last
answer yes I think that Oliver's gonna
defeat Slade and I don't think anyone
expects Slade to be the biggest bad
villain next season again so who could
you bring on to top Deathstroke there's
actually a couple theories I have number
one it could be the organization hive
you know who's in charge of that at the
moment no idea but the organization
itself could be the big villain the
other possibility is a Justice League
villain like Prometheus or Amazo they've
been showing that Amazo boats so freakin
much this season I'm not expecting any
cosmic villains or outright
super-powered villains at least super
villains who don't use technology to
enhance their abilities
I think the flash show is actually gonna
be the first one to tackle real
superpowers in all honesty though I
think Prometheus would be a good fit you
know Aeros version of prometheus plus
there's the whole cry for justice
storyline where ever he chops Roy's arm
off not that I think that arrow would
ever make Colton Haynes limp around with
one arm for the rest of the series that
would just be cruel so thank you so much
for submitting your questions this is a
lot of fun as always like I said next
week is a deep dive into Deathstroke be
sure to subscribe below to get my video
it's gonna be so much fun right now
click here to get my birds-of-prey
review and click here to learn more
about the Avengers 2 villains
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives
you